recently there has been a lot of
controversy surrounding the 20 series
and it's been getting a lot of
negativity so here are 10 reasons why
you should buy an Arctic 2080 and if you
already bought one why it was a great
decision
[Music]
welcome to Argos hobbies now before we
go any further I really wanted to thank
all of you guys for helping this channel
grow to 1000 subscribers I really do
appreciate it and I'm very thankful to
all of you guys so starting off with
number one the Arctic's 20 80 and the 20
series in general will have really good
performance the Arctic's 2080 is
expected to have performance better than
the gtx 980ti
there are some leaked benchmarks
floating around for the artix 2080 but
these numbers should be taken in with a
grain of salt because it's very easy to
take such numbers and it is unlikely
that proper drivers were used even if
the actual car was used in my opinion
the best place to look for performance
of the r-tx 20 is actually from Nvidia
themselves so far we have heard that
performance of the 20 80 maybe up to 2
times as high as a 1080
now obviously anybody's benchmarks are
perfect world scenarios and they were
most likely not applied most of us but
it is a good scope of how well these
cards can perform moving on to number 2
you are getting a lot of new harder with
the RT X 2080 starting off you're
getting GTD r6 memory which is
significantly faster than GTA 5 and GTA
5 X memory also you'll be able to
experience a 12 millimeter architecture
which would most likely be a lot more
efficient and may allow for better
overclocking and finally you're also
getting in your dream architecture as
well so there's a lot of new hardware
surrounding the RT X 2080 so those are
all benefits as well next onto number
three these news GPUs also have a lot of
new technology implemented within them
not only ray-tracing
but also DL SS while ray-tracing
technology is nothing new having real
term rate racing is definitely a nice
benefit and deep learning super sampling
does seem to sound promising as well is
the expensive price worth it for these
new technology well I'm not quite sure
but either way these are nice
technologies to have
number four these are the newest GPUs
available from Nvidia and that comes a
lot of perks buying almost outdated
series of GPUs has a lot of issues and
may lose support soon in the future for
example with the 10 series Nvidia driver
updates and support will most likely
diminish over the next couple of months
and years however with the 20 series
NVIDIA will continue to support the
series for quite a while in the future
number 5 these will be hands down the
best GPUs available on the mainstream
market currently we have Vega from AMD
but really it is not comparable with the
20 Series at least not in performance
and as for AMD na'vi we really still
don't know that much information about
it and it's likely that it will just be
in our alternative 220 series and not a
replacement for it so for the
foreseeable future the 20 series will
dominate the GPU market as the best GPUs
available on to number six and this one
is a bit controversial but pricing isn't
really not too bad now hear me out here
the are 220 80 and GTX 980 seem to have
a similar gap as the GTX Andy and GTX
980 from last generation and last
generation is completely acceptable for
the GT 1080 launch an initial MSRP of
$700 also with the 10 series NVIDIA
didn't really implement new technology
and it was more of a straightforward
upgrade on top of that there weren't
very many outside influences changing
the price for example the DRAM market is
really inflated right now and GT r6
memory is already a lot more expensive
than GTA 5 X memory so this could be
contributing to that even more again
you're getting deep learning super
sampling and real-time ray tracing
technology with the architects 2080 and
you didn't get such technologies with
the GTX 280 so yes $800 for card is a
lot of money but actually does make
sense based on the past and current
market influences now for the Arctic 22
DTI I'm not sure as prices actually that
justifiable but for the art 220 it's
actually not that bad and that takes me
on number 7 and that is that pricing for
these GPUs are not
can it change at least not in the
imminent future we will most likely see
a price drop of around $100 but that
most likely won't come until at least a
year after this launch so if you're
looking to buy a new GPU within the next
couple of months the pricing for the 20
series is really not going to alter that
much you may be able to find some deals
on Black Friday for about $50 or so but
that's really pretty much it moving on
to number 8 if you're considering buying
the fast edition of the 20 series then
something cool about it is that you get
that cool new design we have seen the
same shroud design from Nvidia for
several years now and it really is a
nice touch to see something new from
them number nine these GPUs are pretty
much as future-proof as you can possibly
get these GPS are going to last for
several years and they'll provide a
great performance throughout those years
they will be able to handle all sorts of
gaming sales and produce really high
frames per second and almost all of them
for several years to come
so these are definitely some GPUs that
will last into the future and finally
number 10 and while this one is really
subjective I also think this is one of
the most important deciding factors of
buying the Arctic 2080 and that is if
you actually want the r-tx 2080 if you
want the Arctic's 2080 then you should
probably just go ahead and buy it
because there's no point in buying a GTX
1080 or 1080 - yet and while they are
cheaper than the Arctic's 2080 they're
by no means cheap on their own means so
you really don't want to be spending
that much money not being fully
satisfied with the GPU that you're
getting or having that little urge
between you it every day and that you
should have gone with the arktech 2088
instead so if you really just want to
twenty series GPU I really recommend
that you just follow your heart and go
get one for yourself in the end graphics
cards are meant to enhance our gaming
experience and make it more enjoyable so
it really is whatever makes you happier
but that's pretty much all I have for
you guys this time
did I miss a crucial point on why you
should buy the art 620 make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments I'm
curious as to what you guys think - make
sure to post your thoughts also if you
guys liked via the make sure to like and
consider subscribing if you'd like to
see more videos just
this one but until then I'm Mari I'll
see you guys on the next one
[Music]